c'est historique de nouvelles
habitations verront bientôt le jour dans
le quartier du bois de l'étang à la
verrière 82 exactement cela faisait 40
ans que la ville n'avait pas eu de
nouvelles constructions vous venez à
l'est derrière vous avez deux façons
d'habiter soit vous habitez dans du
logement collectif social soit vous
habitez dans un petit pavillon que vous
achetez sur un terrain de 400 m mais y'a
rien d'autre et donc il fallait
effectivement d'autres formes d'habitat
qui permettent à des jeunes couples
d'accéder dans du petit collectif par
exemple ces habitations sont accessibles
en location-accession mode privilégié
par les primo accédants ce processus
d'acquisition qui date de 1984 n'avait
pas bonne presse mais récemment de réels
avantages lui ont été conférés on
bénéficie maintenant pour ce type
d'acquisition d'une tva à taux réduit
maintenant à 7 % avaient passé de 5 5 à
7% d'une exonération d'impôt foncier
pendant 15 ans et pas de cumul de
charges pendant la construction pour un
trois-pièces comptait 180 mille euros et
240 mille euros pour une maison de
quatre pièces les travaux devraient
commencer en janvier prochain déjà 10
acquéreurs se sont positionnés l'espace
vente est situé en face de la gare sncf
livraison de la résidence prévue début